since we're talking about the threat of
nuclear war and otherwise he asked I'd
be interested in both your expectations
for Human Society if when we move Beyond
Mars
will those societies be industrial based
how will it be governed how will
criminal infractions be dealt with
when you read or watch Sci-Fi what comes
closest to sounding logical do you think
about our society beyond Earth
if Econo has Mars if a colonized space
yeah well I think I have a pretty
a humbling picture of that so because
we're still going to be the Apes that we
are so we when you when you imagine
colonizing Mars you have to imagine a
first fist fight on Mars you have to
imagine first murder on Mars also
infidelity yeah somebody extramarital
Affairs on Mars right so it's gonna get
uh really homely and boring really fast
I think you know it's like only the
spacesuits or whatever the other uh
extension cities of just living in that
atmosphere or lack thereof uh will limit
how badly we can behave on Mars but do
you think most of the interaction will
be still in Meet Space versus digital do
you think there will be do you think
we're like living through a
transformation of a kind
where we're going to be doing more and
more interaction than digital space
like everything we've been complaining
about Twitter
is it possible that Twitter's just the
early days of a broken system that's
actually uh giving birth to a better
working system that's ultimately digital
I think we're gonna
experience a pendulum swing back into
the real world I mean I think many of us
are experiencing that now anyway I mean
just just wanting to
have face-to-face encounters and spend
less time on our phones and less time
online I think you know maybe everyone
isn't going in that direction but
I do notice it myself and I notice
I mean once I got off Twitter then I
noticed the people who were never on
Twitter right and then and the people
who are never basically I mean I know I
have a lot of friends who are never on
Twitter yeah and they actually never
understood what I was doing on Twitter
it's like like they just like it wasn't
that they were seeing it and then
reacting to it they just didn't know
it's like
it's like being on riff like I'm not on
Reddit either but I don't spend any time
thinking about not being on Reddit right
it's like I just I'm just not on Reddit
um do you think the pursuit of human
happiness is better achieved more
effectively achieved outside of
Twitter world
well I I think all we have is our
attention in the end and we just have to
notice what these various tools are
doing to it and
it's just it became very clear to me
that
it was an unrewarding use of my
attention now it's not to say there
isn't some digital platform that's
conceivable that would be
useful but
um and rewarding but
yeah I mean we just have you know our
life is doled out to us in moments and
we we have and we're continually solving
this riddle of
what is going to suffice to make this
moment engaging and meaningful and
aligned with
who I want to be now and how I want the
future to to look right where I mean
that we have this tension between being
in the present and becoming in the
future
and um
you know it's a seeming Paradox again
it's not really a paradox but it can see
it like I do think the ground truth
for personal well-being
is to find a mode of being where
you can pay attention
to the present moment and this is you
know meditation by another name
you can pay attention to the present
moment with sufficient you know gravity
that you recognize that that just
Consciousness itself in the present
moment no matter what's happening
is already a circumstance of freedom and
and contentment and and Tranquility like
you can be happy now before anything
happens before this next desire gets
gratified before this next problem gets
solved there's a there's this kind of
ground truth that that you're free that
Consciousness is free and open and
unencumbered by really any problem until
you get lost and thought about all the
problems that may yet be real for you so
the ability to catch and observe
Consciousness that in itself is a source
of Happiness without being lost in
thought and so what what this happened
this happens
haphazardly for people who don't
meditate because they'll find something
in their life that's so captivating
it's so pleasurable it's so uh thrilling
it can even be scary but it can be even
being scared is captivated like so it
gets it gets their attention right
whatever it is if you like you know
Sebastian younger or you know was wrote
a great book about
people's experience in war here you know
it's like like you can strangely it can
be the best experience anyone's ever had
because everything it's like only the
moment matters right like the bullet is
whizzing by your head you're not
thinking about your your 401k or that
thing that you didn't say last week to
the person you shouldn't have been
talking about you're not thinking about
Twitter it's like you're just
fully immersed in the present moment
um
meditation is the only way I mean the
the that word can mean many things to
many people but what I mean by
meditation is simply the discovery that
there is a a
way to
engage the present moment directly
regardless of what's Happening you don't
need to be in a war you don't need to be
having sex you don't need to be on drugs
you don't need to be surfing you don't
need nothing it doesn't have to be a
peak experience it can be completely
ordinary but you can recognize that in
some basic sense there's only this and
and everything else is something you're
thinking you're thinking about the past
you're thinking about the future and
thoughts themselves have no substance
right it's it's fundamentally mysterious
that any thought
ever really commandeers your sense of
who you are and and makes you anxious or
afraid or or angry or whatever it is
um and the more you discover that the
half-life of all these negative emotions
that blow all of us around
get much much shorter right and you can
you can literally just you know the the
anger that would have kept you angry for
hours or days
lasts you know four seconds because you
just the moment it arises you recognize
it and you can get off that you can
decide at minimum you can decide whether
it's useful to stay angry at that moment
and you know obviously it usually isn't
and the illusion of Free Will is one of
those thoughts yeah it's all just
happening right like even the Mindful
and meditative response to this it's
just happening and happening it's just
like even
the moments where you recognize or not
recognize is just happening it's not
that the the
this does open up a degree of freedom
for a person but it's not a freedom that
gives any motivation to the notion of
free will it's just a new
way of being in the world